Transcription: Louise Roche
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Je m’appelle Sandy,
je suis guadeloupéenne
et je suis profondément fière
de mes racines africaines.
Mais voilà, j’ai un problème
parce qu’il y a quelques mois,
quand j’ai dit à mes collègues :
« cette année, je pars
en vacances au Bénin. »
il y en a un qui m’a dit,
« Tu vas en Afrique ?
Mais tu vas dormir où ?
Dans des huttes ? »
J’ai un problème
parce qu’en classe préparatoire,
dans mes cours de géopolitique
et d’histoire,
on m’a dit que la colonisation
a eu un impact désastreux
sur le continent africain,
mais...
que quand même il y a eu du bon,
il y a eu des apports bénéfiques.
Donc, il ne faut pas trop exagérer.
Voyez-vous, j’ai grandi
dans un pays où, à l’école,
on me parle surtout de Napoléon
et de ces fameux Gaulois
mais surtout pas de Sankara,
de Kaba ou de Sundiata Keita.
Alors après je grandis,
je lis, je m’informe, je pose
des questions, surtout à mon père,
je vais à des conférences,
des expos, et je me suis dit,
mais... c’est bizarre.
J’ai l’impression qu’il y a eu
comme un trou dans mon programme
scolaire dans la partie Afrique.
J’ai l’impression qu’il y a
des choses qu’on n’a pas dit.
Colonisation, esclavage, esclavage,
colonisation, colonisation, esclavage.
Mais les royaumes africains,
on n'en parle pas.
Les grands hommes et les grandes femmes
noirs qui ont changé le monde...
On n'en parle pas.
La première déclaration des droits
fondamentaux au monde
qui a été énoncée sur le sol africain,
- je parle évidemment de la Charte
du Mandén - on n’en parle pas.
A 18 ans, je décide
pour la première fois d’aller en Afrique.
Je décide d’y aller seule.
Je vais au Ghana.
Je reviens du Ghana et je me dis,
mais c’est bizarre.
Des usines, des routes goudronnées,
c’est quand même très différent
de ce qu’on m’avait montré à la télé.
Alors je réalise une chose :
mon histoire,
je n’y connais pas grand’ chose.
Notre communauté, nos communautés,
nos langues, nos cultures.
Je les aime, elles m’attirent,
mais je les connais pas.
Je ne les maîtrise pas,
en tout cas pas assez.
Alors à partir de ce jour-là,
je prends une décision :
tout ce qu’on ne m’a pas appris à l’école,
j’irai le chercher dans les livres.
Alors je lis, j’investis, je questionne,
je songe, j’examine.
Puis j’écris, et j’écris et j’écris.
Et puisqu’on ne trouve pas
tout dans les livres,
je prends des billets d’avion
et je vais voir de mes propres yeux
ce qui se passe chez les miens.
Sénégal, Côte d'Ivoire, Guadeloupe,
Martinique, Kenya, Rwanda.
Je déconstruis peu à peu ce qu’on a mis
dans ma tête pendant un temps.
Et puis j’écris, j’écris et j’écris.
Et des dizaines de voyages plus tard,
des centaines de rencontres plus tard,
eh bien, j’aimerais la revoir,
mon amie Fatou,
et j’aimerais lui dire
que d’Afrique aux Etats-Unis,
en passant par la Caraïbe,
d’Europe en Amérique du Sud,
sans oublier l’océan Indien,
l’Afrique a des enfants
qui vivent à travers le monde entier.
Le monde porte aujourd’hui des Africains
et des Africaines
sur la Terre mère
mais aussi au-delà de ses frontières.
Et comme pour m’assurer
que Fatou a bien compris,
comme pour dire aux émissions de télé
qu’elles ont tort,
pour montrer à mon prof
qu’il y a de la grandeur
dans mon histoire,
alors cette année,
j’ai décidé de tout quitter :
mon job,
mon appart,
ma vie,
ma petite vie parisienne tranquille,
ma famille,
et j’ai décidé de me lancer un défi :
faire dix pays de l’Afro World
en dix mois.
J’ai décidé de me lancer un défi :
vivre mon rêve africain.
Et vous savez quoi ?
Je l’ai fait !
(Musique)
Dix mois, dix pays d’Afrique,
à la découverte des merveilles
du continent, en commençant par...
le Congo,
l'Ethiopie,
la Tanzanie,
le Zanzibar,
le Mozambique,
la Zambie,
avec deux stops
au Zimbabwe et au Botswana
et en pays numéro sept : le Cameroun.
Je veux montrer l’Afrique
qu’on ne nous montre pas à la télé
et partager les expériences
qu’on ne verra nulle part ailleurs.
Sénégal, Rwanda, Côte d'Ivoire, Kenya,
Afrique du Sud.
Ce continent, c'est un trésor.
Et bien évidemment, je suis actuellement
au Bénin, mon pays numéro sept.
Il me reste encore trois pays
pour arriver à la fin de ce défi.
Si vous saviez
tout ce que j’ai vu cette année,
ça veut dire toutes les choses
en commun que nous avons
que j’ai vu cette année.
Quand je vais à la Barbade et que je poste
sur les réseaux leur plat national,
le coucou,
je reçois des dizaines
de messages d’Ivoiriens,
de Ghanéens, qui me disent,
« mais attends, Sandy,
ça, c’est notre plat !
Même recette, mêmes ingrédients.
C’est juste le nom qui change. »
Et quand j’arrive ici au Bénin
et une amie me dit,
« Demain, on va prendre un petit déjeuner,
je vais te faire tester les pâtés
et à midi, ce sera le test. »
Dès que j’arrive, devant ces mets,
je me rends compte
que ce n’est rien d’autre
que le bokit et le riz haricot rouge
de chez moi.
Alors je souris
et je me rends compte que oui,
l’Afrique vit encore
au-delà de ses frontières.
Dans nos langues, dans la musique,
dans notre spiritualité,
dans les mots de kikongo
que je retrouve dans le créole,
dans le rythme de musique congolaise
que je retrouve dans la musique
traditionnelle de chez moi.
Puisque je suis au Bénin, comment ne pas
parler de mes frères et sœurs d’Haïti ?
De la religion que certains apparentent
à de la magie, que je retrouve ici,
dans ce pays ?
Et quand je vais à Gorée
et qu’on ne me parle que de Gorée
et qu’en voyageant,
je vois Ouidah au Bénin,
je vois Bimbia au Cameroun,
je vois Zanzibar en Tanzanie,
Moanda en RDC,
Cape Coast au Ghana,
que je me tiens
devant ces endroits où mes ancêtres
ont été arrachés,
déportés vers des terres éloignées,
avec pour seul bagage
leur langue, leur culture
et leur spiritualité,
et malgré la traversée
et l’environnement inhumain
dans lequel ils ont évolué,
ils ont pris ce bagage.
Ils les ont ouvert et ils ont pris
ce qui leur restait de leur continent,
ce qui leur restait de l’Afrique.
Ils ont pris ce qui a survécu
et sur ces terres inconnues,
ils ont fait preuve de force,
de résilience.
Ils ont créé leur nouvelle langue,
leur nouvelle culture,
parfois même, leur nouvelle spiritualité.
Partageons ce que nous avons en commun.
Apprenons et comprenons
ce qui nous sépare.
Parce qu’au final, nous venons tous
d’un continent qui est le même.
Nous avons tous une histoire
de départ qui est la même.
Alors, découvrons-la,
célébrons-la,
construisons-la.
Enfin, la construire, oui, mais comment ?
J'ai quelques idées.
On en parle un peu
depuis le début de ce speech.
Maintenant qu’on sait que Africains,
Caribéens, Noirs du monde entier,
nous faisons qu’un,
comment est-ce qu’on fait pour s’élever ?
Moi je vais donner deux ou trois idées.
On va commencer
par le commencement : l’histoire
Et pour que vous puissiez
comprendre une idée,
je vais vous raconter une histoire :
celle de la matinée
que vous venez de passer.
Ce matin, quand vous vous êtes réveillés,
la première chose que vous avez faite,
peut-être, c’est d’allumer la lumière.
Et puis pour venir jusqu’ici,
vous avez pris votre voiture, un taxi,
et vous vous êtes peut-être fait arrêté
par les quelques feux rouges
que surplombe Cotonou.
Et pour vous qui nous regardez en ligne,
pour pouvoir écouter nos idées,
vous avez dû vous connecter à Internet.
Certains et certaines voient peut-être
où je veux en venir, d’autres pas.
Mais la matinée que vous venez de passer
a été possible grâce au travail
de trois hommes noirs.
Vous avez allumé la lumière ?
Lewis Latimer : 1879, il révolutionne
les travaux sur la lampe à incandescence
de Thomas Edison.
Il fait passer les pratiques
de l’électricité
à un niveau supérieur mondial.
Vous vous êtes fait arrêter
par les feux rouges ?
Garrett Morgan : 1923, inventeur
du feu tricolore.
Vous nous regardez en ligne ?
Philip Emeagwali, Nigérian.
Il est considéré comme l'un des pères
fondateurs du réseau Internet.
Il a inventé l’un des ordinateurs
de calcul les plus rapides au monde.
Je pourrais continuer encore parce qu’ils
sont nombreux et qu’elles sont nombreuses,
les hommes et les femmes qui ont façonné
le monde d’aujourd’hui.
Point 1 : Histoire
Il est important que nos enfants sachent
ce que nous avons fait dans le passé
pour qu’ils puissent
en faire autant dans le présent.
Les modèles sont importants.
Et le point numéro deux :
on en parle depuis tout à l’heure,
le voyage.
Je voudrais tenter un truc.
C’est compliqué au Bénin,
mais on va tenter : est-ce qu’il y a
des Antillais dans la salle ?
Waouh !
J’ai deux compatriotes dans la salle,
on peut applaudir.
Laissez les mains levées.
Donc, je présume que ceux qui n’ont pas
levé la main sont africains.
Parmi tous ceux
qui n’ont pas levé la main,
est-ce que vous avez déjà été
aux Antilles ?
Guadeloupe, Martinique ?
Un, deux, trois, quatre, OK !
Vous êtes beaucoup à avoir été chez moi !
Mais en fait, c’est ça,
mon vrai rêve africain.
C’est que demain,
dans un an, dans cinq ans, dans dix ans,
toutes les mains restent levées.
Je veux que,
quand un Sénégalais vient en Afrique,
il ne se dise pas que
sa seule option, c’est le Sénégal
mais qu’il peut faire son stage
en Afrique du Sud,
ses vacances au Mozambique
ou en Côte d’Ivoire.
Quand un Martiniquais va aux Antilles,
il peut aller en Guadeloupe,
à la Barbade, à la Jamaïque,
et surtout, comme nous tous voyageons,
que nous fassions le pas
et allions chacun
de l’autre côté de l’Atlantique.
Moi, la vision que j’ai
de la communauté,
c’est une communauté . . .
positive, entrepreneuse,
dynamique et curieuse,
une communauté qui . . .
faisant connaissance
avec la grandeur de son passé
et qui a conscience des atouts
du présent en voyageant
aille de l’avant
et construise son avenir.
Alors, vous savez, ce collègue-là, qui
pense qu’on dort encore dans des huttes
et tous ces gens qui se refusent
à voir l’Afrique autrement,
je pense que notre mission n’est
absolument pas d’aller encore et encore
et encore leur prouver qu'ils ont tort.
Nous, on sait qui on est.
Notre mission aujourd’hui est de nous
réapproprier ce qui nous appartient
et de transmettre, partager à nos enfants
qui nous sommes vraiment,
et de lancer nos businesses,
créer nos emplois,
ouvrir de nouveaux médias.
Notre mission est de reconnaître enfin
notre unité et notre valeur et surtout,
en tant qu’Africains du monde entier,
de briller une nouvelle fois.
Vous savez, je lui en veux pas,
à ma copine Fatou.
C’est vrai qu’on a été colonisés,
dispersés, esclavagisés,
mais une fois qu’on sait ça,
qu’est-ce qu’on fait ?
On pleure sur notre sort
et on regarde nos divisions,
où est-ce qu’on crée,
on se réinvente,
et on revient à la maison ?
Moi, j’ai choisi la deuxième option
et j’espère que vous aussi.
Je m’appelle Sandy,
je suis Guadeloupéenne
et malgré les milliers de kilomètres
qui nous séparent,
malgré les centaines d’années
que séparent nos histoires,
je suis véritablement fière
et honorée de mon identité africaine.
Et j’espère que vous aussi.
Merci et au revoir.